welcome to this video playing back
wounds Rafael this is just the name of
the guy maybe Rafael back ones could be
answer amenia right yeah let's see let's
see huh someone suggested I should try
to play the marshal attack I can try
that but I have no real idea okay we get
one of those various NT marshals this is
the real problem with this with the
marshal attack it's not much latech
itself but you're not going to get it
that often um yeah but now I don't
really have those a three lines of but
some chicken type of approach is
probably not terrible just Bishop e6
them to change that yeah this feels like
a fairly normal position could um
could easily be reached and in one of
those top-level games at least the type
of position maybe not the precise one um
yeah how do I go about this I would like
to take on d 594 maybe yeah maybe I can
trade off some material him who I'm
sorry if he takes seven and plays Bishop
g5 now k it's not that not a super
dangerous pin I guess yeah it should be
all right nothing too too terrible okay
so we just retreats thats this is
interesting i guess the ideas on in case
of a captcha on d5 that he his argument
is that my night does not have a great
square only f5 there is some logic
behind that of course but if i'm not
taking on d5 what am I playing him c3
knight c6 looks also rather uninspiring
okay maybe do that oh wait not so quick
he might take with the bishop it's very
unlikely but it can happen so I'm going
to f5 mostly for the sake of yeah with
the argument that I initiated the whole
thing and don't know what else to do but
this looks nice for why a knight coming
to e4 but this quite quite okay how do I
am how do I regroup I was thinking gee
697 f5 would be nice but he might play
with f4 even here possible maybe even
have for the only thing that in my
favorites that his Bishop is on H
not it's not doing very much there's
some other way I would like to trade of
this night and maybe I can just go here
in fact yeah of course that took me a
while and this is just this is just a
just an ok idea that if intending at
five maybe night to g6 I am interesting
fighting for the center um yeah I come
on i will ever play a fire I don't think
he has a big tactic or anything
sometimes might happen and i take c 5 if
he has a tactic I'm stupid young a first
thought okay why not take on be4 first
and then play a five no ah that would
that that was very bad okay so i take
the six check I know mmm guys lease my
position in her in it as a total ruin
him I need to take first of course oh
wow yeah jelly terrible
yeah my only hope is that this is one of
those guys who plays instant moves all
the time and I'm not sure that this was
any good at all now with Queen g5 I
don't know
okay so i can take h3 right and there is
now a big drawn back here and Bishop
takes g2 Bishop g2 or something else now
that should be this should be sufficient
roof g1 there is some that's more than
one would move actually queen age six is
also quite good threatening double check
mate green age 6 let's just briefly
recheck he has no king white resides
yeah and probably there was other well
there were other things but this is like
a medium yeah at least it's it's a
winner why isn't this a maid I had
because I'm not threatening I made but
it wins young it definitely wins f3 also
wins which was my original idea while
that was a rollercoaster ride yeah
Bishop e3 was was simply one of those
instant moves i again forgot to do
something about the clock times it was
one of those instant moves that that
don't do any good I mean he was having
an excellent position after i blundered
95 I think if I first take yeah and then
go from there I should be alright yeah
nothing it's just a position but I
overlooked that chanting and here the
problem is he has the two bishops and I
have dark squared weaknesses and I don't
know he it's only a matter of precision
how he can maybe exploit those those
weekends
what unstable Center I'm actually
surprised that the computer is only
giving white 0.6 or 0.7 after Queen age
five yeah he is better here that sets
don't like them threatening Bishop g5
yeah maybe I have to retreat to g6
possible this is what the comp is
suggesting yeah and white is better
after we should be three then but here I
mean this is all of a sudden all of a
sudden not clear and after after this
I'm starting to be in excellent shape
and black is so this is this yeah you
can defend better with black as
Winningham yeah there should be three
one of those instant moves that don't
don't cut it right after i blundered
yeah okay I hope you enjoy this thanks
for watching